what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
as soon as we continue our discussion on
all-new all-different marvel what I want
to do here is I want to talk about
totally awesome Hulk now it's something
else I want to want to speak about for a
second this has nothing to do with the
Hulk but something that I do want to
talk about is a question someone had
with regards to like how comics work um
this is probably a topic designed for
chemical concepts but in all honesty
it's not really something that warrants
a full video so much as I mentioned
somebody asked about story arcs trades
on the basis that kind of thing so when
it comes to comic books you have
individual issues the individual
colleagues to come out and then you have
trades which is basically like just a
story arc so if you were to take I guess
Nightwing better than Batman you know
that that whole story arc is the first
six issues I think of Nightwing and it
would be released as a trade and omnibus
is a collection of trades which tell a
larger overarching story so hopefully
that makes sense to you guys but in any
event getting into totally awesome hulk
so again greg packs at the at the runner
you know he's an easy guy in charge of
all this and I really like Greg packet
you know he's a really cool guy to talk
to and I like his writing but in truth
you know totally awesome Hulk doesn't
resonate with me in particular it
doesn't mean it's bad now by any stretch
of the imagination
totally awesome hope is fun and it was
designed to be that way totally awesome
hook was designed to be a fun story and
the reason why is because Greg Pak won
at least when I talk to him anyway he
had stated that the whole basis behind
totally awesome hope was to basically
take the character of Amadeus Cho that
he created and to elevate him to the
main stage because when all-new
all-different marvel was at his infancy
when Marvel was really kicking around
the idea of a possible reboot they had
gone to a lot of different riders and
said hey if you could write any any
character or any story with a particular
character what would you do Greg Pak
said I would make Amadeus Cho the
incredible whole and the result is that
we got this this really kind of like
frat boy Incredible Hulk sort of thing
going on um initially with this story
with with Thor versus Hulk a Greg Pak
constantly does a job of refreshing us
and I don't mean he doesn't like in
every single page I mean that every time
he starts a new story he literally makes
it so that fans can just jump into the
Incredible Hulk anywhere along the line
I think that's important I think it's
important to do that of course you don't
need to do it you know you don't need to
do a full origin story at the start of
every single story arc but it can't hurt
to refresh people a little bit just
because every story is someone's first
story in the realm of comics so I think
it's hard for us as fans to keep that in
mind those of us who jumped on with
all-new all-different marvel and we've
been reading
Iron Man from issue number one some of
us that got on before
all different Marvel and we've been
reading Thor since starter Jason Aaron's
run or even before Jason Aaron's run is
very hard for a lot of us to remember
that there are people who are just now
getting into college for the very first
time and so while it's ingrained in our
minds that yeah of course Jane Foster
store right now you know or of course
Odin's son was Thor before Jane Foster
or of course Nick Fury said something to
Thor that kept him from being able to
use his hammer not everyone knows that
and so the idea is to basically create a
way for new fans to segue into a series
because this is one of the things that
Marvel struggled for with years you know
was the idea that the comics were so
convoluted it was so difficult for fans
to know where to start if that wasn't a
problem channels like mine would exist
but the idea here is that that Greg Pak
focuses very much on the Bruce Banner
element of The Incredible Hulk
with regards to how it applies to
Amadeus Cho and the reason why I say
this is because with Bruce Banner what
he initially became the Hulk he would
quite literally just black out he
wouldn't know what the Hulk did and even
then in the modern day there were times
when he wouldn't know what the Hulk did
now once he became more intertwined with
the whole persona they got to the point
where Bruce Banner was aware of what was
happening he was just helpless to stop
it but the idea is that for Amadeus Cho
this seems to be the case no we'll learn
is a little more going on to this but
this story's just as much setting the
stage as it is for anything else
especially when we get to the events of
civil war - and Hawkeye killing Bruce
Banner but the idea here is that for
Amadeus you know he has some sort of a
nightmare that basically witnesses his
parents explosion where he basically
kind of experiences winning you know
this plane fight competition 2,500 grand
being immersed in his success you know
coming home and his parents house
exploding and in them dying in the
process and when he comes to he's simply
just in the Sierra Nevada you know in on
the side of a cliff and so for him he
doesn't really know what it was it was
going on behind the scenes now the way
that I say this is this is kind of this
Bruce Banner dichotomy coming in is
because Greg Pak from the word go
immediately also established that
amadeus cho knew what was happening when
he became the Incredible Hulk now you
know Greg Pak doesn't really seem to
indicated this is a side effect of his
intelligence or if it's similar just the
fact that Amadeus Cho embraced the Hulk
at least that wasn't the case in the
beginning but what he does is he
emphasizes this in this story the
question that his sister asks is do you
remember what happened when you hooked
out and he says no and that's a huge red
flag for her because he always remembers
because he has total control and look
pack does is he has Amadeus Telus sister
look the reason why Bruce Banner didn't
have controlled the Incredible Hulk is
because Bruce Banner suffered a lot of
traumatic experiences in his life most
of which happened at the hands of his
father
and so when he underwent exposure to the
you know gamma bomb that turned him into
the Incredible Hulk all it really
happened was the Incredible Hulk persona
was a manifestation of his anger it was
a totally separate personality Bruce
Banner quite literally just had multiple
personality disorder but instead of it
manifesting in the psychological form
like it does with Legion it manifested
in a physical form with the Incredible
Hulk and so because of this Banner
didn't really know everything that was
going on with the Hulk in the beginning
before Amadeus Cho he knows it all so
what happens is the sister basically
attached some electrodes to him
basically begins to monitor his brain
patterns as he begins to you know jump
into a hook for but the other half of
this is to see whether or not it's
possible for them to repeat the
experiment now the reason why Greg Pak
also does this is because Amadeus child
and his sister are geniuses and they
follow the scientific method which is to
say if an unexpected situation occurs
then see if you can repeat the formula
to create that unexpected situation
again and then see if you can deduce
what it was that led to that unexpected
situation that's what they're doing
they're quite literally just following
bread crumbs they're trying to see if
they can't figure out why it was that uh
that Amadeus can't remember what he did
when he was home now from here there's a
lot of banter back and forth between uh
between you know Amadeus Cho and his
sister now we could skip over this but I
actually think this is really important
for the character of Cho because this is
again Greg Pak breaking him away from
Bruce Banner now if I'm gonna be honest
with you guys I actually miss Bruce
Banner I really like banners Hulk and
the reason why I enjoyed his hook so
much is because for banner he hated the
Hulk but he needed the Hulk it was a
very much very much a love-hate
relationship banner and a lot of
instances just wanted to be free of this
curse that had been a part of his life
for so long but there were also so many
instances where the Incredible Hulk was
quite literally the one thing that stood
between some villain and the
annihilation of the planet Earth a
really good example is onslaught if Jean
Grey had not separated the mind of Bruce
Banner from the Incredible Hulk and
allow the Incredible Hulk to just run
with unbridled strength and savagery
then you know hope never would have
punched ansan enough to damage his armor
and onslaught would have quite literally
wiped out the earth superheroes and
probably taken over the universe and I
think there's actually a what-if story
based on that I'm sure
summers a what-if story for everything
house Mouse but um but I think the idea
here is for for banner this dichotomy
between himself and the Hulk was just
designed just as much to be the sort of
doctor dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde you know the
light side of humanity versus its darker
half as it was just a cool series of
events with superheroes but for banners
home it was really more of an issue with
writing that's one of the reasons why
Peter David is considered to be one of
the best writers because he introduced
the whole element or at least he
capitalized on the whole element of
banners dad in his violent history and
so on and so forth establishing this
multiple personality disorder kind of
situation you know Peter David had this
definitive run and because of this you
know when Peter David eventually left
the Hulk story started to drop off to
the point where he was much like
Wolverine in the sense of the only time
he ever really had anything going on is
when he would show up he would fight a
film destroy some stuff and they call it
a day but when Greg pack took over the
title when he started writing Amadeus
Cho and even before they when he was
writing the Hulk there was a lot of
great story element going on here and he
continues that with Amadeus Cho you know
the bickering between himself and his
sister is a hallmark of family you know
regpack takes this very human element of
what makes Amadeus Cho who he is and
what makes us you know somebody that we
can relate to and he says this is him
this is you know his bickering this is
you this is your life in comic book form
it may not necessarily be exact I mean
you may not have lost your parents and
you may not be a giant green rage
monster but the idea is that in some
form or fashion you probably have
sibling rivalry and some former fashion
you bicker with your friends and family
this is much the same way in what goes
on with this story and so because of
this you know once Amadeus begins to
realize that he doesn't at least it
seems like he doesn't have full control
of his faculties he sort of goes on this
self journey you know trying to figure
out what's going on with him but the
result is it along the way while he does
come across a couple of puppies and so
on he's met by a more of the enchantress
now in the realm of Marvel Comics Amora
The Enchantress was designed to be this
woman that is extremely beautiful but
her beauty is her weapon in the sense
that she can basically ensnare people
with how attractive she is and then use
her various magics to bend them to her
whim now she tries us with the with with
Amadeus Cho an incredible hope she says
hey look I'll give you whatever it is
that you want I'll give you anything
that you want you know all you have to
do is swear allegiance to me now the
funny thing about this is that amour is
very much a sexual character I mean you
know there's you know we're not going to
shy away from this she was very much
designed to be a care
after that embraces sexuality and in
fact in the ruins miniseries where was
like the worst case scenario for for
superheroes when you know things were
really screwed up she actually became an
adult film star but the idea here was
that she was designed to be a character
that uses her sexuality as a way to
ensnare largely men and get them to do
things that she wants them to do in this
instance she's working alongside
Malekith now again this this shows as
how I guess you know for lack of a
better word you know the cohesive nature
of the more the all-new all-different
marvel landscape works is not really
cohesive it is to a degree but it's just
kind of scattered different matters
doing their own things and it's kind of
weird it leaves you without a feeling of
wholeness
but in stories like this there is some
bedroom wholeness there in the sense
that during Jason Hermits run a Jane
Foster Thor is dealing with Malekith
basically rallying a lot of the villains
or those individuals who want to cast
off the Asgardians and replace them with
their own rule and rule their own realms
Amora The Enchantress is much like that
now the reason why she goes to the
Incredible Hulk is because folks are
forced to be reckoned with I mean you
know when it comes down to it a Hulk has
unbridled strength and when he's really
at his angriest when he's at
you know his peak in terms of savagery
uh when he's devoid of any real measure
of empathy or really human emotion the
Hulk could take on almost anybody from
as you are the only exception of course
would be like the all-father Odin Thor
you know with the Warriors madness I
mean there's obviously characters from
Asgard that he couldn't take on but I
would say 90% of the forces that exist
in Asgard he could take on you know in
his absolute angriest form well breaker
Hulk is a whole nother discussion but
the idea here is that for a more to
basically ensnare the Hulk to her cause
would mean that she'd be able to lay
waste to a huge portion of Asgard the
issue with this is that what she tries
to ensnare him and even uses you know
images of his of his parents being
killed as a way to dupe him he doesn't
initially buy into it you know he
initially says I am NOT Bruce Banner
alright I'm not you know this
emotionally unstable guy you can't just
dupe me this way and so she simply just
starts manifesting she uses her powers
to manifest you know rocks and they
start turning into giant monsters and
they actually start to attack these
puppies now the reason why this is
important is because amaura's magic is
usually confined to the person that
she's using it on in the sense that she
can cast hallucinations and that's what
she does well you know Incredible Hulk
or while Amadeus chosen his hope form
fighting
giant monsters eventually he's ensnared
by her actions and he ends up joining
her and we don't exactly know what it is
a two of them do but when he comes to
his sister tells him look I was watching
you I was monitoring you with the
satellite you were just punching rocks
and so to anybody who was watching you
know the event that was not from other
days chose perspective he was just
running around the desert punching rocks
into the ground but from his perspective
he was fighting giant rock monsters and
so what we end up doing is we basically
find that Thor arrives to the scene and
Thor you know Jane Foster says you need
to come with me you know one you're
obviously every bit of a monster that I
thought you were and who you are
essentially a villain now initially
amadeus cho doesn't know what she's
talking about he's like look you know if
it was the Hulk I don't remember what I
did you know my mind is absent and
that's what we're trying to figure out
is why I don't remember these things and
even when you know when Jane Foster and
Thor get into a fight with one another
of course him in his Hawk form he's
perfectly aware of what's happening
right now so it was an abnormal
circumstance that led to him forgetting
everything of course we know a more the
Enchantress probably had something to do
with it but more so than this the by
between Gregg outside of the fight
between uh between Greg Pak and Thor the
fight between Thor and Amadeus Cho Hulk
is important here because of the fact
that it shows us where Jane Foster
stands in relation to the Hulk when it
comes to strength when it comes to
unbridled fury Jane Foster is not on the
same level of Odin's son we just kinda
need to throw that out there right now I
love her stories I think Jason air is
doing an amazing job I think she adds an
incredible element to the Thor mythos
that we desperately needed for some time
but when it comes to a knock-down
drag-out fight she cannot hold her own
on the same level as Thor can and so
this was Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk he
would smash her into the ground most
likely I don't know that he would kill
her but she certainly wouldn't be able
to put up much of a fight but Amadeus
Cho isn't necessarily as strong as
Banner was with unbridled rage just
because of the fact that he's so in
control of himself and so because of
this the fight seems relatively even but
it's really more of you know of Jane
Foster trying to figure out what's going
on so as we end up joining her and
Amadeus Cho traveling to the realm of
the dwarfs we learned that because
Malekith is working to basically wipe
out the dwarves and steal their
technology or steal their mining
abilities to forge weapons of his own on
that they had basically taken all these
tools that they had all these different
metals and these precious materials and
they had put them in
and a secret outpost on earth now of
course the reason this was done was to
keep them all out of the hands of
Malekith and his forces but more so than
that because of the the actions of a
more the Enchantress when amadeus cho is
unconscious but he basically broken into
the realm of the drawers and stolen her
metal now uber metal is a material that
makes up force hammer and so what this
seems to indicate is that as one of the
hardest materials in existence with the
exception of true adamantium that a more
the enchantress is basically having
these drawers or having having the Dark
Elves of Malekith forged weapons that
can be used in Malik kis attempt to take
over all the realms that are attached to
the world treated Raziel and Asgard and
so because of this of course you know
Amadeus Cho figures us out Jane Foster
figures us out Amadeus chose sister
figures us out and they go to where it
is that a more the enchantress is at now
the way they're able to do this is by by
having Amadeus chose sister build a
machine they can basically detect the
residue of uber metal in the atmosphere
and so once that was done it was
literally just following the trail of
where they went to it wasn't anything
wildly difficult but once they get there
a more The Enchantress initially
believes okay cool the incredible hoax
here he's on my side but then he
immediately starts turning against her
and battling her forces now of course
during this time he also reveals a few
things to his sister in saying that you
know with the images that I saw the
illusions that you know more The
Enchantress made me she she revealed to
me that that basically you hate me
you're angry at me because of the fact
that our parents died and that is
essentially my fault no Greg Pak doesn't
explore a whole lot of this it's
religious sort of Amadeus Cho revealing
to his sister that he knows how she
feels about him now maybe that he'll
expand on this in later stories but for
the moment it's just kind of creating
this rift between the two of them this
is one of the issues when it comes to
pact writing Incredible Hulk at the
moment is he kind of dropped these small
little tidbits on character development
sometimes they go somewhere and
sometimes they don't now granted some of
these things may also be out of Greg
hatched hands in terms of what it is
that he's able to write but Greg patch
also a guy that holds things off for
much later stories and so that's one of
the reasons why his writings kind of
hit-and-miss here but when it comes to
when it comes to to a sister talking to
him she says they look you know yes I'm
angry at you but that's fine you know if
you're if you're raged if you're upset
if you're mad at yourself you know don't
be mad at yourself for what happened
be mad at a more to the Enchantress
because she's the one we need to be
right now as though it's really just
kind of
flexing his anger away from her and
deflecting it towards a more which he's
successfully able to do of course he you
know initially runs up on a more she
thinks that he is on her side because
you know she hands him in who grew axe
but then he uses the Guru axe to attack
all of her forces to obliterate you know
these Dark Elves and then you know a
more the enchantress is said running
once she is electrocuted by Amadeus
chose sister and is threatened by Jane
Foster thorne so this basically kind of
you know alleviated her plans for a
while but it's very least it really just
seemed to be an excuse to have Thor and
Amadeus Cho Hulk fight one another but
to be honest with you guys um you know
this really seems like it was part it
was designed to tie into the writing of
of Jason Aaron but that's one of the
other issues here is in all honesty this
story didn't really go anywhere and it
didn't really do anything it was kind of
like well why is it here but again this
is probably really part of Greg Pak just
building up to bigger things and again a
lot of it was focusing on his character
focusing on Amadeus Cho I'm focusing on
the fact that in some form or fashion
you know he is a guy still trying to
figure out who he is when it comes to
the Incredible Hulk more so than that
when it came to the main civil war ii
event which will cover of course once
that event finishes there was a glimpse
from ulysses that you know the
incredible hulk was going to re-emerge
and was going to tear everything up and
the perception was edwards Bruce Banner
which resulted in the death of Bruce
Banner and the trial of Hawkeye so this
really seemed to be Greg Pak leading
into that particular set of events but
again I don't know this is editorial
control or exactly what's going on
behind the scenes but this particular
two-part story really seems to fall out
of line for what Greg Pak normally does
which is why it's sort of took me by
surprise it just seemed like it was just
spinning its wheels but at the very
least you know it gives us a kind of an
interesting event with Amadeus Cho Hulk
fighting Jane Foster it's never a bad
thing to see Thor fighting Hulk is
always fun to see so anyway guys if
you're new here to comics explain which
you guys hit the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video drop a like and leave
a comment down below let me know what
you guys think about Amadeus Cho Hulk
let me know what you think about about
this story and I will catch you all
later peace
you
Nik